having me and thank you very much for
Global Citizens leadership indeed from
the pandemic
to fighting climate change the climate
action
and thank you very much for this
opportunity to address
such a diverse audience
your leaders from politics business
Civil Society
but you share the same responsibility
and the sense for this responsibility
and the idea
that we are all Global Citizens so it's
very good to be here and thank you very
much for having invited me let me start
with the basics
and that is
the dramatic reality
of a boiling planet
just a month ago I was in Greece
Greece a country that was ravaged by the
worst wildfires in Europe in living
memory
and only a few weeks later
the same country was hit by three years
worth of rainfall
in just three days
this is the reality of climate change
the same is happening from Libya to
Slovenia from Spain to the Philippines
so climate change is Among Us
now you wonder how can anybody still
have doubts
well some still wonder whether climate
action
and economic growth
can go hand in hand and our answer is
yes and we are proving it
with a European green deal and our
climate law
we became the first continent to make
climate neutrality a legally binding
Target by 2050.
then we've set emission reduction goals
for 2030 we've developed a road map
and today we are on track not only to
reach those goals in 2013 but to
overshoot them
so this is really good news
this road map to climate neutrality
has fostered Innovation and investment
and why that
because business found the necessary
reliability and long-term predictability
this is so important just stay the
course they need this reliability
just a few days ago for example I was in
Denmark
and I inaugurated the world's first
container ship powered by Green methanol
and the ship owner mersk told me that
when he planned this ship
it was a bad business case
but he wanted it
to try out how to decarbonize his Fleet
but then
we launched the European green deal
so the direction of travel politics was
clear
and all of a sudden what appeared to be
a bad business case turned into a first
mover advantage
and we've seen Innovations happening in
Europe which otherwise would have been
very much difficult to achieve
for example the first green steel
factory
when we started the European green deal
Europe had none
today we have 38
Europe is now attracting more investment
in clean hydrogen
than the United States and China
combined
we have the first carbon capture and
Storage
so
our climate action is not only good
policy
but it's also a good business case and
that is the news for the business sector
today
more and more countries are joining the
cleantech race
they want to get away from the old brown
energies like gas oil and coal
they want to protect
the green lungs of the world
while growing the economy
I saw this with my own eyes and you
mentioned it here earlier this month in
Nairobi at the Africa climate Summit
I must say I was deeply inspired by the
confidence
and the optimism of my counterparts
president Ruto of Kenya captured the
spirit when he said and I quote
for a very long time we have looked at
this only as a problem
it is time we flip it
and look at it from the other side
end of quote and I couldn't agree more
developing economies
are a crucial part of the solution to
climate change
with a huge potential for renewable and
clean energy and green hydrogen for
example
critical raw materials incredible nature
and biodiversity and their young
Workforce
so they can lead frog into Clean Energy
Future while creating good jobs
and economic opportunities
provided and that is a crucial point
provided there is investment they need
in infrastructure
so too often emerging economies lack the
resources to invest or they cannot
access resources
the big question is
how can we close the world's clean
investment Gap
and major economies like Europe have an
important role to play we have an
obligation
let me go through a few topics
the European Union Remains the world's
biggest climate Finance contributor
we contributed more than 27 billion US
dollars
to climate Finance
that is more than one-fourth of the
global 100 billion goal and I'm very
confident that this year at cop28 we
will reach that goal we will finally
keep our promise
then we have our investment plan we call
it global gateway it's up to 300 billion
euros
where we are financing clean
infrastructure across the world in
developing countries and Emerging
Markets
of course we also need to recalibrate
the International Financial system so
that it can better support climate
action that's a big topic that we're
discussing at unga in these days
and there are many interesting proposals
on the table from sustainable
development called stimulus by Secretary
General buteresh to the discussion on
depth restructuring
but I want to speak today about
private investment
public money from major economies
however crucial
is simply not enough we need to work
even closer with a private sector
and that's what I want to talk about and
let me briefly introduce four ideas to
you
first green bumps
second
carbon pricing
the third is carbon credits
and finally as a force Point Global
renewable energy targets
on the first point
the Global Experience shows
that green bonds are key tool
immobilizing private capital from
private investors
that want to make investments in climate
positive with climate positive impact
that's a good tool but however despite
the rapid growth in the recent years
we've seen that the green bond market
remains largely dominated by Europe the
United States and China
while the developing countries
that would really have a benefit from it
struggle to access their potential
so this is why we launched the global
green bump initiative
Europe as I said has the biggest and
most advanced green bond market in the
world so we have quite some expertise
and we do now share this expertise with
developing economies
so that they can create their own green
Bond markets
and in addition we will invest 1 billion
Euro in green bonds
of low and middle income countries
and this has a double effect
we are de-risking the private investment
and we are acting as an anchor investor
so this could yield up to 20 billion
euros in sustainable investments from
the private sector
so my message to the business Community
is don't miss the training be part of
the Dynamics of these fast rising
economies that's the message
second point
carbon pricing
carbon pricing is a market-based
instrument
and the principle is very easy
you want to pollute
you pay
if not
you innovate
clean up your products decarbonize
so carbon pricing Fosters Innovation by
the private sector
it makes polluters pay
and the revenues you get
can support the clean transition in
developing countries
and let me give you some figures
we started in the European Union carbon
pricing in 2005.
since then
the economy grew by 65 percent
but the CO2 emissions dropped by 35
percent in the industries that are
covered by carbon pricing so we grew the
economy while cutting emissions
now if you look at the global scenery
globally
only one quarter of greenhouse gas
emissions are covered by carbon pricing
but this quarter brings back revenues of
95 billion dollars
so just imagine
the global impact
in terms of new revenues while cutting
greenhouse gas emissions
if more countries would adopt this
strategy the carbon pricing this could
be a game changer for climate Finance
and this is our call for action for
carbon pricing that we want to launch we
have launched it in Paris and we want to
have a big push for it at cop 28.
my third point
is trustworthy carbon credits
carbon credits can truly make a
difference to the planet
The crucial idea is
governments have projects like
reforestation or renewable energy or
wetlands
companies
can then reward those efforts in
addition to their own efforts they can
invest there
but what we need now
is an international framework that
provides clarity
and clear criteria
what are trusted true carbon credits
so we've started to work on that with
the World Bank the IMF and the WTO we
want to make as much progress as
possible by cop28
and I invite all of you to engage in
these discussions
and my fourth and final point
if we want to limit the temperature rise
to 1.5 degrees Celsius
we need to speed up the global clean
transition energy transition
and that is why I think that we need
Global targets by 2030 because we all
know only what gets measured gets done
if you just have the goal and you do not
have the trajectory you'll never get
there only if you know exactly where you
want to go they have a clear goal and
you measure it every year then the
things get done
and this will show the companies the
direction of travel again predictability
reliability stay the course
so to get there by 2030 we need Global
action
and therefore
we are building a coalition
with the cop 28th presidency
with President Ruto of Kenya
with prime minister Mia Motley of
Barbados
and the International Energy agency and
Irena
our goal is
for the world to agree at cop 28
to Triple renewable energy capacity
and to double Energy Efficiency which is
energy saving
and we invite all countries to join and
we need to get this done
excellencies dear friends
audacity to think globally
is our own only option in this climate
critical period
I think with together with our friends
all over the world and with critical
supporters like you here in the room
we're able to make it so let me thank
again
Global Citizens for bringing us together
and let me wish all of you a very good
conference thank you for listening thank
you very much
thank you
foreign
[Music]